pour théo champagne un allié au bureau
tous les matins revient à descendre dans
un stationnement parisien au deuxième
sous-sol se niche le projet de ferme
souterraine que cet entrepreneur de 27
ans a lancé il y a plusieurs mois comme
vous pouvez voir un c'est un espace qui
est à moitié en production et à moitié
en travaux alors que d'autres
agriculteurs urbains choisissent-ils toi
lui a opté pour des espaces de
stationnement d affecter son entreprise
émergente site l'opo nits a reçu le
soutien de la mairie de paris et d'un
bailleur social
une dizaine de personnes travaillent
désormais dans cet endroit
rebaptisé la caverne
dans cette champignonnière en partie
dans l'obscurité leur shit ac est une
sorte de cèpes japonais et leur
pleurotes sont certifiés bio il pousse
sur des substrats végétaux les premiers
champions sortir après deux semaines dix
jours de semaine après c'est ballot ils
vont me donner pendant encore deux mois
à trois mois environ
il y aura plusieurs récoltes qui vont
nous permettre de récolter de pleurs
autres comme ce à quoi ils en produisent
actuellement entre 100 et 200 kg par
semaine mais il rêve déjà de récolter
plusieurs centaines de tonnes de légumes
par an dans cet espace clos où il n'ya
pas d'aléas climatiques
un peu plus loin carole basso nos
ingénieurs s'occupe des herbes
aromatiques et des jeunes poule 2
poireaux de tournesol mentor de moutarde
celles ci ne sont pas cultivés sous
serre ou en pleine terre mais sous des
lampes led
on a différents types de l'aide qui sont
composées de différentes combinaisons de
rouge et de bleu car en fait les plantes
elles captent le rouge et le bleu dans
le spectre lumineux et nous ici on
essaye de reproduire le spectre du
soleil ces champignons césar ces micro
puce ne sont pas pour l'instant vendu à
des particuliers mais à des commerçants
des environs qui privilégie les produits
venus de région parisienne
alors tous les matins c'est la même
routine ici il prépare plusieurs
dizaines de cageots par choix
les produits sont récoltés le jour même
pesé et directement livrés à vélo en une
vingtaine de minutes
la marchandise arrive à destination
une épicerie maison que des produits low
to certaines personne sont un peu
sceptiques quand on explique que voilà
ça se fait directement dans paris c'est
vrai que l'environnement est très pollué
il se demande si c'est pas ça pas une
influence sur la nourriture directement
mais en leur expliquant bien que la
cedeao autorités
adapté pour la production de champignons
dans l'ensemble ça se vend très bien
bientôt des endives seront produites
dans cette caverne agricole après un
ancien bunker de guerre à strasbourg
l'entreprise sèmera aussi ces graines
dans une cave à bordeaux ici je dit
chétrite radio canada à paris